good evening everyone thank you so much
for joining us
I'm Ryan Murphy and I have the distinct
honor of introducing mr. James W Ceaser
James W Ceaser is the Harry F Byrd
professor of politics at the University
of Virginia where he directs the program
for constitutionalism and democracy he
is also a senior fellow at the Hoover
Institution dr. Cesar received his PhD
from Harvard University and has been a
visiting professor at Claremont McKenna
College Harvard University Laval
University Marquette University and the
George Marshall Center in Germany from
2008 to 2014 he served as a presidential
appointee to the National Archives
Commission he's a frequent contributor
to the national press and comments
regularly for the voice of America he is
the author of several books including
presidential selections reconstructing
America nature in history in American
political development and designing a
polity in addition he has written
extensively on the presidency and
presidential elections having
co-authored a series on each national
election since 1992 please join me in
welcoming mr. James Caesar
Oh Thank You Ryan for that kind
introduction and I'm happy to be back I
was here I guess in pre escalator days
and nice to ride that that's well I envy
all the other speakers in this
conference whose task is only to treat
the history of a political party from
beginning to end or to deal with the
specific election by contrast the
organizers have tasked me with the duty
of discussing the whole party system its
origins its development and its future
as well and this being Hillsdale College
where the party system fits in with our
constitutional order so the topic is
enormous I won't say huge so no time to
tarry here are a few of the empirical
observations I'll be making they're kind
of obvious first the party system ranks
right up there in importance with the
institutions of our government President
Congress and Supreme Court you can't
discuss America without discussing the
party system witness this conference yet
parties as Matt mentioned are nowhere
mentioned in the Constitution mentioning
doesn't mean approval or disapproval but
we know from looking at the text of the
Constitution and even a brief look at
the thought of the founders that they
never contemplated parties in the form
that we have now is full in an elaborate
form they never thought they would exist
and their observation was that it would
be detrimental if they did still this
was a free society and I find no way in
which they thought they could have
banned parties legally in the United
States so there we were at the founding
parties the party system have been
enormous ly influential in the American
political system here they colored
and inflicted all the institutions I
mean the constitutionally the president
supposed to be president of all the
people Washington take took great pride
in that yet our presidents now are
conspicuously partisan to take the
current president who's gone so far as
to campaign against one of the
candidates while he was on foreign soil
not exactly
president of all the people having
donated $1 to him in 2008 I received his
emails since then every single day and
their partisan in character and I think
this reflects the the notion the
president isn't simply the president of
all the people anymore in Congress does
it act as Congress as a unified body or
more as a contest of parties one always
supporting or usually supporting the
president and protecting him the other
opposing him in some ways trying to
embarrass him so you could go on and on
to see how parties are enmeshed in the
operation of our government and there's
another descriptive point I'll add this
is for those who are interested in
comparative politics I wanted to say
that in this respect that though our
parties modify the constitutional system
the constitutional system also affects
the character of our parties because if
you look at some Europeans states where
the parties is where have been given
free rein and practically are the
Constitution in a parliamentary system
in the sense that they they set the
whole government government grows out of
party government it's really the core of
the constitutional arrangement whether
you have a majority in parliament in
those systems we see parties fully
developed the logic of parties fully
carried out so they're sometimes called
party governments but not so in the
united states however important parties
are offices
still partly count and influence the
government in spite of parties so you
have but just to take the current
election you have
the speaker Ryan making it clear that he
would support Trump if he's elected
president but that he feels he's there
to check him and Marco Rubio said in a
way I'm running in president partly to
check him we find innocent the
representative representative function
is not dominated by parties and some of
the times it's even less important than
the classical conception of
representation and this is one of the
few countries where this classical idea
of holding in office as an individual
lies with the party for influence over
the political system now those are some
of the empirical claims I'll be making
these empirical claims raised almost
spontaneously some speculative or
evaluative or normative issues right off
the top I'll want to touch up on a few
of those today as well one is this well
some since parties formed early in the
United States and since they're so
pervasive and seemed looking back so
inevitable I think it's fair to ask
whether the the problem here is not with
the addition of parties as over and
against the original Constitution really
the question might ask is the problem
with the Constitution and the founders
is this a important blind spot in their
understanding of politics or not then
you could ask did the addition of a
party system strengthening important
constitutional government make it better
as Matt suggested or is it made
constitutional government worse and
there's a real complication here this
goes back to a point that John Locke
spoke of the imperfection of language we
think that what we use a term like party
system that it refers to one thing and
the mind goes around in circles trying
to say what that is yet very often we
find that a word like party system or a
term actually embodies several different
alternatives and in fact in with the
question of parties we see that parties
are not the same thing at different
times even by their nature as we'll see
they're not the same thing so that
you ask the question whether parties and
a party system is harmful or beneficial
you have to ask it which party system
and what kind of parties as these change
finally parties since they are not in
the Constitution though they are
embedded in our political system now
still the fact that they aren't in the
Constitution means that they don't have
constitutional status and it's fair to
ask will parties last will they endure
or could we see in the future in fact a
very near future a future without
parties in the sense we have now or
parties that are performing somewhat
different functions than they have now
well so much by way of introduction
let's go right to the the Constitution
and what's conspicuous in the
Constitution and where we see the
absence of political parties is in the
method of presidential selection
otherwise known as the congressional
college there's a misimpression that
American the Constitution created three
national institutions President Congress
and court actually created four the
fourth is the electoral college fully
spelled out in the Constitution
now that institution is still active at
the endpoint today as is in the final
selection of President that's why we
count up the electoral college the way
it's those are the ones who finally
decide the president but this is the
point that's overlooked about it the
electoral college in its original form
it was not meant just to perform the
function that we perform in the final
election it was a institution to do to
handle the entire selection of
presidents from the beginning to the end
in other words the Electoral College was
if you want to put it in modern terms
the winnowing device the nominating
device and the electing device so in a
way it takes the place of or what meant
to cover what we now have in
primaries conventions campaigns and the
final election all that was to be
handled by the electoral college what
were some of the objectives of this
institution well one of course was to
find good people who would become
president the founders were less
concerned with the glories of the
campaign than the preparation of
selecting someone for governing that
came first
whereas today were it's a country which
is in some ways become obsessed with
campaigns which endure well over a year
are highly entertaining grab attention
it's almost as if the fact that they'll
have to govern one day is subordinate to
that now the the selection of the
delegates and and the electors and the
president on the original system could
be fairly popular as a good deal of
popular influence involved in this
system but the interesting thing was
there were to be no parties and really
no campaign in the modern sense as
candidates would not go out and vie for
office this would be handled by the
electoral college and those of you are
older than the students will remember we
used to nominate our candidates a little
bit this way before there were primaries
the candidates vying for the nomination
of a party at the convention didn't
normally go out and campaign widely
before the the convention it was left to
the convention similarly it looks like
the electoral college was supposed to
handle this without a public a public
campaign which the founders thought
could divide the country that's add to
divisions that weren't there before I
could read a passage from Federalist 68
and I should Hillsdale College the
process of election affords a moral
certainty that the office of president
will seldom fall to the lot of any man
who is not in an eminent degree endowed
with the requisite qualifications and
then it goes on to say the station will
be filled by characters
pre-eminent for ability and virtue so
that's what is held up it was also to
prevent these are the pop of the pus
site to put some in like that but also
to prevent certain things because the
founders looked on this national
election is a dangerous period that
could could cause crises in particular
to prevent demagogic candidacies or what
they call the low arts of popularity so
that people would for their own ambition
choose to achieve the office by you know
in some ways harming the public whipping
it up dividing it putting their own
interests obviously above the country so
this was the great danger and it goes
back to the classic concern that the
real reason for the fall of democracies
has to do with demagoguery so the system
that we have that i described in the
founders it only lasted a couple of
elections but it fulfilled perfectly its
objectives we had two elected elections
under the under the electoral college
and sure enough we selected someone
preeminent for virtue it's a hundred
percent accurate in what it did
washington was elected two times before
this system more or less partly went out
of business by contrast we can look at
what we have today 2016 where we no
longer have this system so here's some
bad social science look when we had it
we got washington we look when we don't
have it we look at today now you have
two perfect test cases clearly this is
the worst choice ever in american
history that we face this election
pitting one candidate who's corrupt and
dishonest against another one who's
erratic and demagogic oh I forgot to
mention the third candidate Gary
Jacobson oh gee I forgot his name
yeah mr. Johnson and it's not a sin that
he doesn't know what Aleppo is after all
I have some good friends who don't know
what Hillsdale is but but the fact is
that in a way he took a very interesting
political philosophy of libertarianism
which has a theoretical pedigree and he
really has turned it into something
different his party's become a pop party
really and I think that's the extent
he's in a way harming the brand of
libertarianism meanwhile in addition to
the candidates being the worst ever look
at the campaign it's a race to the
bottom and it's hard to imagine that he
could get much lower look at the subject
matter that has entered this campaign
which we now take for granted but it it
has characteristics with which we've
never seen in campaigns or at least when
they've been seen before because
scurrilous charges have been uttered
they've been uttered for the most part
not by the candidates themselves but by
those working on their behalf to put a
little bit of distance between the
candidate and these charges which is
pretty important thing because this
person whoever it is will become
president in January and is now directly
both of them are directly tainted with
these charges that are made against the
others neither candidate and here was
another purpose of the electoral college
it was to create confidence in a
candidate coming in or at least not
undermine the confidence that people
would have and that's pretty important
with the proper president to enter with
confidence beyond a group even those who
support them a general sense of
confidence what if there's an early
crisis in the next administration or a
president as all president does makes a
grave mistake neither candidate will
begin this term with a large degree of
confidence of the American people which
is a dangerous constitutional situation
to begin with well so clear then that
from from this institution of the
electoral college that the party and the
founders did not expect there would be
political parties it was to choose an
individual
parties nevertheless did form in the
1790 so let's take a look at them for a
minute and learn at least about one kind
of party so I mentioned parties have
different forms with these first ones
well people in parties sometimes will
come together with an aim or purpose in
politics to shape the political order in
some way and in this case this was why
parties did form the Jeffersonians
democratic-republicans which we can say
is the first party to have organized
they formed out of fear worried they
worried about the subversion of
constitutional or at least the Liberal
Democratic regime they saw Alexander
Hamilton's program of development which
was supported by many in Congress and
they said look this means we're heading
down an unconstitutional path with an
expansive national government whose
powers extend beyond what was
constitutionally granted and partly it
begins with an argument over the
Constitution and the power that was
generated inside of the administration
let's say the presidency reminded the
Republican Democrats that this was could
be an institution in the government
which was trending towards monarchism so
it was really a party which formed
against the threats of monarchism and
beyond that you can look a little bit
more deeply there was a type of person
to that the Republican Democrats sought
to create a person who was independent
in himself and that was especially the
the the independent farmer who was God's
chosen people Jefferson said hedges bet
if ever he had one but that was the
farmer so it was anyway an idea of a
rural virtuous citizen that was what
what the Republican Party Democratic
Republican Party stood for the
Federalists by contrast did have a
program of expansive development using
the federal government the bank
financing protection of industries to
get the economy going so
a strong use of national government with
a strong presidency in some ways
resembles capitalism in the sense of
developing and entrepreneurs and
recasting and remaking society and the
economy but capitalism without less a
fair that's that's what's the
distinctive contribution if you will of
Hamilton a critique in some way of Adam
Smith at least for a new nation to set
things up and get capitalism going and
beneath that also a type of human being
that was favored an individuals who work
despite energy or entrepreneurship and
that would bring in that time if not
independence to everyone in the country
independence to the nation which would
now have an economy which could supply
the materials and the wealth for
protecting ourselves and they in turn
returning the favour' back feared the
Jeffersonian Republicans who they
thought were Radical Democrats Jacobins
using the term from French undermining
the system as it were but by extending
views of democracy far beyond what the
Constitution had in mind
now there's a logic to parties as they
get started you can see this today
forget about what we we call the parties
Democrat and Republican there's logical
parties you can see when a new group
forms and could be a party take say the
Tea Party which is has no name party to
it to now people get together they have
this purpose what is it that they want
to do well eventually Tea Party never
quite got fully to this point but if it
had become a party they want to win
offices in order to achieve their
objectives that is take control of
enough pieces of the government to
achieve their purpose and in doing so
they do what parties do first which is
usually to take a name Federalists
Democratic Republicans a name so that
they can present the party the purposes
of the party to the public then nominate
parties must nominate it's so important
for this reason if you allow
side the people who believe in your
views to put forth three or four
candidates that is or all seventeen
candidates what the heck all seventeen
and the other side only puts one you're
most likely gonna lose even if that one
is Hillary Clinton that this this is the
issue and wait what the party has to do
is put the principles of the party above
the ambitions of any individual and get
everyone to sign on to the idea we're
not going to divide our votes but we're
gonna concentrate them therefore we have
to select one person it's a logic of
nomination psalmist's the first thing
that parties do and in this case in the
1790s that's what the parties did begin
to do using in this case the members of
the party in Washington they called the
caucus of Congress to choose the nominee
that was the nominating instrument but
nomination is is essential to concert
your voice and then to coordinating
campaigning obviously in an effort to to
win as many offices as possible and in
the in the context of campaigning and
raising attention for your party
communication is essential it's not by
accident therefore that the a lot of our
communication system in the United
States was originally a creature of the
parties they had to get their message
out so they sponsored newspapers started
newspapers tried to get newspapers
spreading across the country they funded
newspapers in many in many cases so the
the media controlling the media and
building the communication system was
important our press began as a partisan
press in the United States now what's
interesting about these first people who
formed these first parties is they
didn't care at all about a party system
that wasn't what they were about
well historians ascribe a party system
to them and they said oh that's the
first party system they never sought to
achieve or establish a party system what
they wanted was that their party would
win win and finish off the other party
forever it was an emergency instrument
in fact you
as these people engaged in party
building they never argued or rarely
argued for anything like a party system
and in fact they would soon shave their
objective of one party going out of
business so through the 1790s and into
the second decade of the 19th century we
find therefore the the idea that parties
are detrimental constitutional
government persists even with an among
those who were engaged in party building
they wanted it to end they never
defended a party system or the
legitimacy of a party system as part of
our constitutional order there were many
remarkable implications of parties
forming some of which I've already
alluded to it how changes think but the
first is what it means to have an
election I guess in the original system
if you try and imagine how it would have
worked the selection of offices
president could be fairly popular
certainly the members of the house could
be popular votes but the point was that
each election would be separate as
individuals running it in every
congressional district and the president
not tied together by anything the
election of person in each place now
with the introduction of party something
new and hears or becomes at least
potentially possible an election which
is that you can tie the various office
holders together and speak of the
election now is indicating a national
inclination or national majority so that
you can read an election now to say the
nation wants to go in this direction in
other words we didn't merely choose a
number of officers we chose a party and
a direction and so Jefferson interpreted
the election of 1800 when he won in a
way this was a vindication he thought of
his party and its aims well I did ask
the question at the beginning where the
founders naive to think that parties
wouldn't exist well well maybe but not
as naive as you'd think
because it turns out that it was a long
time until we actually established a
party system certainly not in these
early years where we had part
and that really maybe till 1836 or
eighteen forty more remarkably as this
when the Federalist Party died out by
the end of let's say eighteen twenty or
so we had this period known as the era
of good feeling and it didn't mean that
people got up early and exercised and
did their jogging that wasn't it the air
of good feeling meant precisely that we
have no more political parties were back
in some ways to the original
constitutional design and the
interesting thing was that the dominant
people in Washington including the
President President Monroe they praised
the air of good feelings they celebrated
the facts that that fact that party came
to an end and from what we can tell from
the historical record is that almost all
in Washington were of this view that
well finally have gotten rid of parties
we're back where we were or at least
some resemblance of what we had and this
is how the system should operate one
person or one group was a little bit
suspicious of this and that person is
martin van buren later became president
but this point in 1820s he was a young
senator from new york and he kind of
liked political parties from operated
them quite well in in state of new york
he saw them as a way for a an average
politician like himself who didn't have
much renown or flair or military record
to make his way up after all a party can
wait confer stature on you you don't
have to have it yourself you don't have
to be charismatic if you're a party
person the party will away support you
and that that was sufficient he found
something attractive in this but the
most important reason for his now moving
to establish the party system was the
election of 1824 what was the election
of 1824 that was election where was only
one party so therefore no parties no
nominating process anymore one party why
nominate or no parties you had five or
six running to give you an example of
the election of 1824 would be something
like this forget about the Democrats
suppose they didn't
exist look at the Republican nomination
17 people running for the same office
this is pretty much what Van Buren
thought would happen with the presidency
and what did happen in 1824 five or six
or seven candidates started running for
the presidency not nominated by parties
and this is what Ben Buren believed was
the good constitute the great crisis in
American politics in what sense well
there's a technical constitutional sense
unlikely that any candidate will end up
with the majority of the electors
therefore the election will go to the
House of Representatives which is a very
unsatisfactory way of choosing a
president even Madison thought so each
state gets one vote so a problem with
that and this was Van Buren said in a
way if we want to avoid the house
election which will become the norm in
the future without parties we really
need some instrument to stitch together
majorities and achieve a majority in the
electoral votes so that's one point but
the main point had to do with the
character of the way the candidates
solicited the office here
van Buren argued was ambition unleashed
an ambition instead of channeled towards
establishing a record of service that
people could admire ambition out
channeled in the direction of soliciting
votes by the low popular arts in short
demagogy and the consequence was that
you had six or seven candidates he said
running around each appealing to some
part of the electorate because you
weren't going to get the majority in all
likelihood some part of the electorate
and therefore looking for a base but not
a broad broad coalition then you could
hope to be one of the three that would
get into the house and win the election
but first stage is divide and divide Ben
burns said by section in particular the
crisis therefore that he saw looming was
that the country would fall apart
because of how we choose our president
fall apart because of demo' goujian
sectionalism no way to stop it or
unlikely to stop but he believed the
solution therefore he argued was to
establish and now we get this word a
party system
a party system as a way of addressing
this problem so you could look at and
for the original people who were
involved in parties parties was more
important than the party system for
martin van buren the party system was
more important for the proper than the
parties the parties were the instrument
to get the party system going but the
party system was most important to him
it was like a new institution of
government only not that adopted but
through the Constitution but performing
a constitutional type function so van
Buren was involved in this project for
the next number of years very
complicated ways but it's a masterful
performance to try and change people's
minds about parties from the view that
prevailed in the era of good feelings to
what finally occurred by 1836 and 1840
so in a say 16 year period at the outset
of which almost everyone in Washington
said national parties are a bad thing
1840 apparently almost everyone thought
Oh parties are part of the political
system as much as anything else that was
the revolution in thinking which with
which he was involved now
what were some of the things that he
wanted from this party system well he he
needed parties so enough partisanship to
keep the parties going yeah they have
some ideas but he really wasn't terribly
concerned with what those ideas were as
long as they met certain criteria the
parties should be national and safe so
they should have principles but they
should be principles that would have
appeal across the nation so we would
never divide by sections and safe
meaning not too extreme or radical that
would be enough to keep it going
parties would have this advantage as
well these would now become the
instruments for controlling ambition any
serious person who wants to become
president now has to go through the
political parties he hoped and therefore
has to subordinate his personal ambition
to these moderates and national parties
you can't get to be a nominee unless you
follow what the party stands for and the
party is supposed to stand for something
safe and
national that's the way to the
presidency think that way don't think
like the candidates in 1824 did you
won't get anywhere so all these
instances people are thinking about
channeling ambition and that was
foremost in Van Buren's mind and
suppress demagogy which was the bane in
his view in some ways he was trying to
do what the Electoral College originally
did in a new setting using the parties
to achieve this objective well another
thing about these parties which is
interesting
were they the real parties in this sense
of what people wanted as a purpose in
government in a way they were meant to
cover up what might become the real
purpose they were meant to cover up the
division of north and south
they were meant to push it in the
background and Harry Jaffa in his book
writes he says well the real party's in
way were latent and formed as early as
the Missouri Compromise in 1820 we saw
the what the real divisions were I think
van Buren realized that the idea was to
use parties to push it in the background
kick the kick it down the road ensure
that these parties nominate candidates
who don't represent simply the sections
that was that was his home so in some
ways the parties instead of performing
that original role of forming to push an
end are now formed in a way if the
system works they're formed to dampen
conflict so we have parties are
two-faced possibilities parties as
instruments for change that come
together in the views of people to
reform or completely remake the society
or the government and parties understood
in another way that the safe instruments
that are part of the system in the
United States that dampen conflict and
that exist in a way to keep the
dangerous issues out and if you look at
political science there are two schools
that study parties some of them laud and
parties they say oh look what they've
done for moderation okay they're a
little bit corrupt but the price of
corruption is great they stay together
they hope they assure compromise they're
not too too hung up on ideology and then
you have the other view which parties
are the instrument is Bernie
sander says for our revolution the name
that he gave to his super PAC just after
he purchased the nice property on Lake
Champlain
well what were these parties very
quickly the two parties that formed in
the 1830s at Van Buren Health Forum were
the the Democrats maybe chasing back to
Jefferson but the Democrats and he he
expected they would have pretty much the
same view that is fear of an overweening
central government more power in the
states
favoritism a little bit more to the
agrarian interests of the country there
was one problem that emerged quickly
that also gave impetus to this second
party system namely the opposition party
which took the name of Whigs they were a
little bit like the old Federalists
party's national program of development
stronger national government weight
modernization of Hamilton's old ideas
but the main impetus actually came over
a person Andrew Jackson who assumed
powers with a popular support that
frightened the Whigs so in some sense
the Whigs were against monarchism
against King Andrew so the party of
Hamilton if you want to call it that was
now became the party that was opposing
the presidency whereas the Democrats
were the party now that favored the
presidency in a popular presidency so
this was a new you say impetus of the
parties that mixed up the the strict
continuity that exists well these
parties that came they didn't last for
that long and if you look at 1836 I say
1840 is the first pure example of these
parties with conventions now politicians
choosing the nominees all the stuff we
sell we indicate torchlight parades
mechanisms of communications remarkably
large organizations relying on patronage
at the local level a lot of the stuff
that was the old stuff of American
politics all that came in 1840 and after
but by the time you get to 1850s and
1856 this party system is already in
trouble by virtue of a new kind of party
or rather a party that was in inform
very much like the parties of the 1790s
and that was the Republican Party here
was a party that didn't form to be part
of the party system I don't remember
thinking saying I want to be part of a
party system they were a party that was
formed to change and transform to do
something about slavery in different
forms to adhere to principle in a way to
draw a line a sharp line what you have
for example not house divided speech and
it's interesting to see the reaction to
this party by good and solid people a
wig the wig party which is kind of a
Conservative Party from which the
Republican parties emerge but one of its
leaders great jurists rather great
lawyer named Rufus Choate and he instead
of following Lincoln into the Republican
Party became the enemy of the Republican
Party on what grounds simple
says if we are going to keep to the
Constitution now not the formal
Constitution but the party system
parties must be national and the
Republican Party is not a National Party
therefore the Republican Party is a
threat to the Union as indeed it was but
a threat to the Union no one can accept
a party like this so in a way he had in
mind that the the party system was now
an integral part of the American system
and that by starting a party which was
primarily sectional or was in a way we
were acting unconstitutionally I put
that in scared quotes not against the
legal Constitution but against the ideas
that had established this party system
and so so many thought there we see
therefore the two aspects of party's
dynamic instruments for change and
viewing parties also as instruments to
avoid change or at least to keep it
within bounds well the party system that
developed afterwards only mentioned the
Republican Party which remained the
party of government after the
Civil War as more active larger use of
government a national party that would
be active within civil rights but also
in protecting businesses as a
protectionist party in tariffs for
reasons may be to help business but also
this was the way to get money for a
larger federal government and so the
Republican Party remained the party of
government in fact it remained the party
of the national government up until
really after the New Deal then the
Republican Party as we know it today
parts of it became frightened even as
Jefferson had become frightened about
what the national government could do if
it was too extensive namely not a party
to encourage and develop business but
really a party to establish what already
in the 19th century was guarded as
socialism something that would kill
capitalism so the Republicans by the
time you get to the into this century
and especially after the New Deal begin
now to be the party of limited
government and laissez-faire rather than
the party of government for the
development of the economy well the
final step in this is the progressive
movement and what it did to a party
system which takes us pretty close to
today really it took the progressives a
long time to get what they wanted but by
1972 pretty much what they had proposed
it come into being
they had another view of what parties
were and what the party system was so
again can't use the word party system
because these are almost a different
entity what was the progressives issue
before you get to parties you have to
understand that the progressives I mean
the leading intellectuals we're an anti
constitutional or anti anti
congressional party that's not a
condemnation that's a statement pretty
much effect in fact what they worried
about and what they didn't like about
the original Constitution was the fact
that it dispersed powers and in modern
government they argue to handle the
demands of an industrial and economy you
couldn't have two institutions going in
different directions you couldn't have a
Congress checking a president
and leading to all sorts of difficulties
of getting anything past what you needed
was a central point where authority was
vested and this became de facto the the
executive so that's where power should
be vested this way the part the
government can act two favorite words
efficiently and coherently didn't have
to put up with this compromising and
this give-and-take and rationally of
course is the progressives were social
scientists and experts working under the
president could now devise the programs
that we needed to manage an economy and
later on to manage a welfare state and
later on to give us a bomber care if you
want to look at it that way from John
Dewey to Jonathan Gruber
well what about parties in this now
parties are second to second place in
one respects the progressives early on
they praised parties at least in this
regard parties were the one thing they
said that at least allows the President
and Congress to get together in some way
and overcome a little bit the separation
of powers so they they saw something in
parties which was superior helped the
Constitution the problem though was the
character those parties these parties
they said were corrupt and beholding to
politicians who paid a press for a price
namely patronage to keep their parties
going and therefore the national
conventions the National Party's
selected low-level people chose second
Raiders but if this new system was going
to operate of concentrating power in the
executive it had to be a dynamic
executive executive who if not one who
set forth principles all the time set
forth a vision who captured the
imagination of the American people
that's what was needed so the parties
had to change you had to get rid of the
old parties and establish a new kind of
party which is what Woodrow Wilson and
many of the other progressives wanted
those who would vie and become say even
by for the nomination would be great
orders instead of their experience in
government it was their capacity to be
able to
a message to the American people to
capture them to elevate them what about
the risk involved in this process
well progress who said demagogy was
likely a thing of the past
we don't have to worry about this in the
modern age in the modern age where
people are more enlightened where things
are more transparent we don't have to
worry about that now we can count on
ambition impelling people to be of the
caliber in their oratory of say Woodrow
Wilson or Barack Obama and who fits this
image perfectly what they're for Wilson
and others proposed back then and
venture lates that we reached by the
1970s was elimination of the Convention
and the politicians is the gatekeepers
for the selection of presidents not
presidential nominees to replace it by
primaries and the voters this is where
the the stars could shine where the
process of the campaign now is so
important where we could watch these
people in action and see them selling a
message or proclaiming a message to the
public the parties therefore would
continue only they would form now around
the individual leader instead of the
party being over the individuals the
individuals is now the over the parties
the parties form around the individual
it becomes his party Obama's Democratic
Party which is pretty much it and the
party now serves as an instrument really
to subordinate Congress assume a
majority party always in the same for
the Congress and the presidency the
president is the natural leader of the
party not to Congress the party will
normally follow the president hence you
get this concentration of power which is
which is desire so that's the new kind
of party which we have whether it's
realized these objectives of high-minded
politics rather than demagogy whether
the campaign is as elevating those of
course are questions which stand very
much at the forefront today I mention
one or two other points in about this
new system parties when they they formed
originally and throughout all the 19th
century
we're entirely private associations by
that I mean they got together just like
the tea party did they form they gave
money together they organized they had
no legal status or standing they were
like any other Association say a a
drinking club legally speaking so that
was very supple of what they could do
they could make whatever rules they
wanted of course they had to be
cognizant of the fact that they were
vying for votes so the rules they might
wanted had to in a way appeal to the
American public but they decided the
forms of the party the rules for
nomination and everything else entirely
to the parties but they were performing
such public functions I mean after all
that here they are really performing the
function at the national level that the
electoral college was supposed to
nominating could you really just leave
them on their own or as this discussions
at parties indicated did this now become
a kind of constitutional question not in
the Constitution but a constitutional
question and so what we have is a
transformation a complicated
transformation of the legal status of
parties mostly by the states governments
which begin to move in and to regulate
parties to tell them to do this to set
up the rules for primaries whether there
will be open primaries or closed party
primaries parties in wait instead of
being wholly private are now partly
public utilities performing public
functions in ways which raise questions
of whether parties will have the
suppleness in the future to change and
transform and yeah that's for the for
the lawyers something I'm not but an
important issue
well what about parties in the future
today you might wonder what the future
of parties will be obviously there's
within the Republican Party that is the
risk of two parties forming out of one
looks like it could come apart in some
ways but that's happened before where
you have two factions but enough maybe
to split the party altogether but the
more important thing would be the
structural elements our parties really
needed in the way they once were parties
perform this function of communica
pation of touching the voters organizing
them and bringing him to the ballot box
do you need this anymore the most
fascinating thing about what has
happened over the last 20 years is that
the cost of communication is zero in the
United States one human being was one
little instrument can send out a message
to every American and it doesn't cost a
penny of course there's a question of
whether they'll listen but this is now
possible which has never been possible
before and so some of the things that
parties can perform are no longer
necessary so do we really need parties
or will parties in some way give way to
some new organization by organizational
form or challenges from outside such
that they'll lose their capacity I would
say the only way that parties might be
able to battle back will be to change
their legal status and insist on new
ways of nominating their candidates
thank you very much
thank you very much dr. Cesar we now
have time for a few questions please
raise your hand and the microphone will
be brought to you Bob Harris over the
past I guess a couple days ago the
Detroit News which normally has endorsed
a Republican candidate for the past I
believe 140 years has now endorsed a
third-party candidate named namely the
Libertarian candidate and I have two
parts of the question one is if a
third-party candidate was able to get
enough votes to so that neither of the
major candidates got a majority of the
vote which they you know maybe only get
4045 percent would this not then tell
that person that they no longer have a
mandate from the people that's the first
part and the second is if it does happen
to go to the electoral college because
nobody gets enough votes how I know each
state gets one vote but then who do they
vote for can they vote for anybody okay
well first question you actually look
many many times we elect presidents with
less than 50% of the vote Bill Clinton
both times so a mandate is a not a legal
it's a rhetorical instrument so there
isn't gonna be a president who doesn't
claim a mandate except maybe George Bush
had to be careful in 2000 but but they
all claim mandates and I think from
people in the Republican Party this is
something that frightens them they know
that if Hillary Clinton wins
she's the day up to election she's not
going to say I won because so many
people didn't like the opponent first
thing she's going to do is claim some
sort of mandate you've endorsed the
third term of Barack Obama this I think
frightens many Republicans and leads
them maybe sometimes you know move in
that direction now the other point that
you mentioned yes if no one gets a
majority which is 270 electoral votes
then the top two
go to the House of Representatives House
of Representatives votes by state now
how it does this is not prescribed in
the Constitution it says they get one
vote
you have to get a majority of all the
states so it's up to the congressman's
presumably and and the legal situation
has not been worked out there's no laws
but this but presumably the state's
caucus among theirs if it's one like
Wyoming caucus is very quickly now
there's a one possibility if the
delegations are split that states won't
be able to vote maybe you would never
reach the requisite majority now what
about the way the congressmen vote
people assume in normal times that
they're going to vote for their party
whatever their state does that would be
the first inclination so that would mean
assuming looks like it now that that
would be the Republicans if you go state
by state would have a majority but will
the Republicans vote vote for Trump it's
up in the air there's also another
theory or they a pressure look we
elected you in Congress from our state
we expect you to do what our state did
regardless of what you did we go where
the state goes so the lots of different
conflicting ideas that come to bear and
it's it's unsettled I mean this is what
what the congressman would have to
decide in this event
what if you don't get a majority then it
then it becomes because who's elected
vice president wait the thing out the
vice president becomes the Acting
President that's another story
earlier you are saying that the only
possible future for the two-party system
is changing their legal status and their
method of selecting a candidate to run
could you elaborate on that how would
they change their nominating process
well there's gonna be a look at the
rules this time I mean there is
something strange in the fact that the
party well what is the party is it the
people who vote or is it the people who
work for it all the time but let's say
it's more of the latter you know the
people who identify and are doing all
this stuff for the party that think it's
their party and MIT maybe rightly so
something strange in the fact that they
they felt that they didn't control the
nomination in fact that the person who
won the nomination in the Republican
Party was not a Republican in any sense
it certainly wasn't a conservative and
said as much almost the same thing
happen appeal in the Democratic Party
this person called himself a socialist
never was a Democrat until a couple
months before the election not primary
and then afterwards went back to being
adept how can you have a political party
that allows its name to be taken over by
someone who's not so there's gonna be
some changes may be coming up there
always are but maybe more radical ones
but my direction would be to think that
that party should disassociate
themselves OC ate themselves with any
legal regulation and claimed themselves
again to be private associations rewrite
their rules as their own hold their own
forms of primaries and caucuses and
justify this people people would say
well aren't you performing the public
function of nominating actually sort of
sort of a public institution that would
say their argument would be no we're a
private Association and if people don't
like the way we do it they can start
their own party so you would have closed
parties but an open open seriously to
third parties to move in and out which
is the check I think we do much better
in that direction I'd like to see the
state to get out of business of
Elections in a lot of ways why does the
state publish the ballot everyone should
bring in their own ballot
which would be easily done now and every
people are voting on internet they get a
copy of it do it the way they want to do
it we have time for one more question
parties have seemed to evolve the
democrat the republican party now is not
what i grew up with from childhood it's
it seems to be that was governing the
evolution of the parties are factions
and the factions are becoming so strong
that i am wondering at some point could
our whole system implode because it's
not based on the principles on which it
was founded it's based on the factions
that our demand making demands that at
some point cannot be fulfilled well that
can happen in my party you know can risk
splitting and it's hard to say in
advance but i and say this about this
problem the republican party let's say
if you look at it isn't that factually
divided when the campaign began it was a
conservative party with nuances i
wouldn't call them factions i wouldn't
say that the difference between Ted Cruz
and Jeb Bush was that great yeah they
differed on some issues but they they
could live together inside of a party if
you take those as the the polls they
were roughly a conservative party with
differences among conservatives so in
some sense the Republican Party was
unified except for this one candidate
who relying on many people who voted
Republicans introduced a new you call
the faction or a new dimension or new
movement into the party and in some ways
what happened is analogous to what I
said about the original reason why
parties nominate if this has been
logical the Conservatives would have
gotten together and nominated instead of
having sixteen of them they would have
said it's time for one so that we don't
divide our vote so much that someone
gets going and steals the party from us
that's the reason why parties nominate
they didn't nominate and so you had in
this case
Jeb Bush thing and longer than he should
have I don't know for whatever reason
maybe he felt he owed err to his donors
but he was finished after New Hampshire
others put their own ambition above they
say why should I take the sword now I'm
not saying that by that point any
Republican could have beaten but
certainly he was able to get going
because the others had divided so in a
way this is an institutional failing
there are always potentialities an
apology for division and faction these
are always there the question is whether
institutions play some role in
moderating them or stifling some for the
time being and you know the fate of the
Republican Party if it had chosen such a
nominee and if it had won both ifs would
have been to see whether someone like
that could have governed successfully
that's where American politics look like
it was going you had Obama's election
twice but then you had the Republican
Party say in its conservative phase
winning almost all the governorships of
the United States the Congress two times
it looked at this this is where the 2016
election was going to be some kind of
conservative running against the third
term of Obama and the nation would
decide so we didn't get that we didn't
get it in part because of an
institutional failure it could have
happened they could they could have
picked such a candidate and it just kind
of got out of hand now we'll see the
results some people are happy with it
they see some advantages in Trump that
conservatism frankly they think had
reached its endpoint
I don't believe that I think
conservatism was on its way up with all
its difficulties and we would have seen
whether we had a government somewhat
like Indiana or Illinois that was the
test that the nation wanted that's red
versus blue that's what we've been going
for the last really the last eight or
ten years this building up where do you
want to live that would have been what
the national government and the national
government would that have been a
Republican Party with that type of
president controlling both houses of
Congress and almost all the
number of the states and state
legislators a position it hasn't held
since the 1920s so that would have been
the test and we're not going to have it
we may get something more interesting
who knows what the future will be but
that's an institutional failure